everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve another graph problem
walls and gates so we're given an m by
n grid where each position
could have three possible values a
negative one which represents a
wall aka an obstacle that we're not
allowed to
visit we're not allowed to visit these
walls a
zero which identifies a gate so
this is an example of a gate in this
case and the third value
is infinity which basically represents
an empty room
and basically for every single empty
room aka every position that's marked as
infinity initially we want to identify
what's the nearest gate to that room and
then we want to take the distance
uh from that room to the nearest gate
and then replace
that infinite value with it so and
if it is impossible basically if an
empty position cannot reach a gate
in our graph then basically we're going
to leave that position as
infinity so for example let's take a
look at this example
uh the easiest one over here right how
far away is this
empty room from a gate well it can go in
two directions it can go down
which is an obstacle so we're not
allowed to travel in that way
we can't go up or to the right those are
out of bounds but we can go to the left
and of course right next to it happens
to be a gate so what we're gonna place
here
is a one meaning this is one position
away from a gate
and similarly this one how far away is
this from a gate will one
two three positions right from a gate so
we could put a three here we could put a
two here and a one here
uh what about this one we could go one
two three so it's three positions
from this gate but it happens to be that
there's a closer gate
if we go to the right and then we go up
right so the closer gate is actually two
places away so we're gonna put two
in this position and now what happens if
there was a gate over here what would we
mark these two as well basically they
start out as
infinity and we would leave these two
positions as infinity
so any positions that cannot visit a
gate are going to be
remaining as infinity so the first idea
that you might have for this problem is
basically for every position we want to
know what's the closest gate why can't
we just run a dfs right
basically a dfs until we reach the gate
or you know we reach as many positions
as we can when we return what was the
closest gate
to that position right and then do that
for every single position in the entire
grid now what's the time complexity
going to be
of that well a dfs is going to basically
be the size of the grid and we're going
to do that for every single position in
the grid so basically it's going to be
something like m by
n squared so the question is can we do
better than this big o time complexity
well let's try out a bfs
solution right we tried dfs let's try
out breadth first search and see
what that leads to us let's say we
started our bfs
at some arbitrary position like this one
is it possible that we can eliminate
repeated work if we do that
well we're gonna start here and then
visit in all four directions
and see you know what's the closest gate
that we can get to
so starting here we have a distance of
zero it takes us a distance of one to
get to these positions and then finally
we can get a distance of two
to get this position right but since we
don't want to revisit the same node
twice the same position twice
we're gonna you know do exactly that
once we get to a position we're gonna
leave it as visited so
you know if we go from here to here it
takes us two positions so you know then
we can say okay for this position it
took us two but when we go
up right we get to this position you
know we can't really go in any other
direction so basically this is going to
be remaining as a dead
end we're never going to get a distance
in this position right because we don't
want to revisit the same position
twice we can't go back in the direction
that we came from
so a bfs solution starting from the
rooms is not going to work if we want to
get an actual
o of m by n solution it's not going to
work if we do it from the rooms but
let's reverse our thinking a bit why
don't we do a bfs solution
from the gates so for example from this
gate we can say okay let's mark all
adjacent rooms basically as saying okay
all of the adjacent rooms are one
distance away
from this gate and then let's continue
that so from
you know this room doesn't have any
other rooms adjacent to it but this room
does
so we can say okay for this room it's
two in this room it's also
two this is two positions away from this
gate and we continue right we say okay
this room is three
and continue from here this room is four
and from here
similarly right we'd say okay this is
three this is four
and this is four right but is that
actually true is this room
four positions away well we forgot about
this gate
right so a better way of doing this
would be to
simultaneously do a bfs from both
gates at the exact same time so in that
case if we ever reach
a position so let's let's see what
happens when we do a bfs simultaneously
so from here we're going to say this is
one these two are one position and this
is also one position now
from all of our ones we're going to
continue the bfs right so
from this one we'll say these rooms are
two away from this one we'll say this
room
is two away right now from this
uh room right this is two away we're not
gonna go to this position and say that
it's three positions away because with
this has already been visited
we've already found the minimum distance
that this is away
from a bfs right so every time we expand
one layer
we're saying okay first let's find all
the rooms
one distance away from a gate next let's
find
all the rooms two distance away from the
gate
and three and we keep doing that until
every single
position in our grid has already been
visited or we
basically cannot continue and we know
bfs solutions are implemented with a q
so once our q
is empty that's how we know we can stop
so let's just continue a little bit more
so from this to
the only unvisited neighbor is this one
so this is three
positions away this one is also here
so now we're going to do a bfs from the
remaining threes
we can see only this three actually has
a neighbor
so we'll say this one is going to be
four and when you take a look at the
actual
output that they built our solution
exactly matches what they did and we
didn't have to revisit the same node
twice
all we had to do was initialize our
queue with the
two initial positions for the gates
and then expanding outwardly basically
incrementing the distance every time we
complete a
full layer of our bfs uh traversal
and that actually led to us having a
time complexity of
m by n we're also going to have that as
the memory complexity because we're
going to have a visit set to make sure
we don't visit the same position twice
but once you kind of know that this is
going to be a bfs from multiple sources
at the same time implementing the code
is pretty straightforward if you know
how to do bfs
so first things first let's get the
dimensions of our grid so the number of
rows and the number of columns i usually
like to do this at the beginning
so and we're also going to have a visit
set that
is going to make sure that we don't
visit the same position multiple times
and we're also going to have a q which
initially
let's uh set to being empty but we're
gonna initialize that with the
gates first of all right so now let's go
through every single position and
actually initialize
our cue right and we know we're just
gonna do that with the gate so we're
going to go through the entire grid
so iterating over the entire grid and
even though we're doing this it's not
actually going to change the overall
time complexity so we're going to go
through every position
if rooms at this position is equal to
a gate meaning it's equal to a zero
then we're going to add it to our queue
so we're going to say q dot append
this position and let's make sure to add
it to the
visit set because we don't want to have
to visit this same position twice
and now we can actually start doing our
bfs so initially the distance is going
to be zero
because we're gonna be popping the
actual gates first of all so
we're gonna say while q is non-empty
we're going to go through every single
position in the queue currently right
basically
this layer of the queue and
so we're going to be popping from the q
so pop left
from this q we're going to get the
coordinates of the gates that we
initially added right that's going to be
the first
layer the first layer we're going to be
popping are the gates that we just added
right
so for each gate we're basically going
to say okay
let's change this gate to being the
current distance
so since the current distance is
initially zero and remember the gates
start
out as having a value of zero we're not
actually going to be modifying the value
of the gates but the reason i'm putting
this line here is because
after we pop the gate layer the next
layer that we're going to add to our
queue is going to be all the rooms
that are one distance away so after this
for loop
let's make sure that we remember to
increment our distance
by one every time we complete a full
layer of the queue
and so basically for this room let's
just go ahead
and add room we're going to add every
single
neighbor of this room and you can see i
haven't actually defined that function
yet so
let's do that up above once i actually
write this out so basically what i'm
doing is
going to be adding all four adjacent
rooms to the queue
and and we obviously know that some of
these rooms might be out of bounds some
of them might have already been visited
that's why i'm going to put this in a
helper function to basically abstract
some of that logic for us so let's
define the function up above over here
so add room we're just going to pass in
a couple coordinates
so basically if this row is
less than zero or if the row is out of
bounds meaning it's too
big meaning it's equal to the number of
rows
or the exact same thing for column if
column is less than zero
or column is too big or
if this position row column has already
been visited
or one last condition basically if
this room is a wall
or an obstacle right because remember
not every position in our graph
is a empty room it's it could it's
possible it could be
a obstacle meaning it's equal to
negative one so if
any of these above conditions is true
we're going to immediately return
because this is an
invalid room so we're not going to
actually add it to the queue
or the visit set but if it's not invalid
that's when we can go ahead and say okay
visit
dot add to the hash set and go ahead and
queue
dot append to the hash set as well
right so basically you can see why i'm
putting this stuff inside of a helper
function because we don't want to have
to call that four times
and i don't really want to put a loop in
here because i just think it's kind of
messy i'd rather just write it out like
this
but so with all of that done we can see
that we have added the rooms we're
making sure to increment the distance
every time we complete a
layer and we're basically going through
rooms labeling what's the minimum
distance
from that room to a gate once we're done
with that we don't actually have to
return anything because we just have to
modify
modify the room's 2d array in place
so this is all the code that we're
actually going to have to write so you
can see that this solution is
efficient we're basically visiting the
entire grid a couple times i think two
or three times because of course we have
this initial loop and then we actually
have to run our bfs solution
but it's still a linear time solution
with respect to the size
of the input array so i hope that this
was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching